what do you guys think of nfts i i get
it but i don't get it at the same time i
understand that there is um there is
value in it as a digital receipt of
sorts but also paying like five million
dollars for a crypto punk that's just a
pixelated thing yeah it's just like why
because because it's scarce
it's a bet on the ability or the
eventual ability to like do something
tangible with these assets sure i think
like no yeah i agree i don't know like i
think there's going to be a like a time
where we actually have like
digital art frames that aren't just like
digital picture frames like we have now
but they're like encrypted and
cryptographically
verifiable so that any picture you see
in one of these you know the person owns
the rights of that or or like with the
board a yacht club it's like there's a
there's an actual club that like once
you buy one of these things that you get
access to this discord and it's like a
social club basically and so they've
built a kind of a community around it
where like the tangible thing that's
attached to this is your membership yeah
yeah i think in that case it kind of
makes more sense oh it makes total sense
tonight rich people coming up with a new
way to exclude people it's not even rich
people i think it's it's artists in in
creators this is like a soho house for
people who don't shower
yes
yeah you buy into the board api and look
at when this guy bought it at 4 48. this
was started by uh
the guys who made hundreds the clothing
line
oh so it's kind of like hype beast
streetwear ish vibes got it slash crypto
guys right so still
a soho house for skaters who don't
shower yes got it yes yeah
because we all know skaters don't shower
and so you can you're the only one who
can see it
no no no that's the funny part no
because this is it right here we're
looking at it yeah you can
oh that's the one yes but he just owns
the receipt yes okay he owns he owns
this picture on the blockchain basically
and like you said though it's it's
basically it's more than just a picture
it's a ticket that gets you into the
discord and gets you into an exclusive
club yeah that makes more sense than
just owning it yeah i think that's the
thing that that screwed up a lot of
people's um perception and understanding
of these is because they started as just
like oh you could buy a jpeg yeah for a
million dollars and it's like okay why
but there are so many
you have to really
take the long
long view of it like you are let's say i
like
own one of these and i want to increase
the value or make it seem like they're
worth a lot more yeah and i have two
wallets
and i have six hundred and one thousand
dollars
can i just buy my own piece
for six hundred thousand dollars to make
it look like the price went up yep yeah
don't they do that already
they must yeah yeah that's there's a
term for that
and i wanna say it's money laundering
but it's not because that's not it's
it's a wash it's basically a wash
[ __ ]
man it's a washer
that's an accountant no no wash [ __ ] and
it's a wash that's the one part that i
feel keeps cropping up with it is
the capacity for fraud is
so high how do you mean like i it's
almost like
i'm not gonna say easier
but you know like to wash money with
real money right you have to like go
open some [ __ ] business and you know
you have to like run money through it
you have to have people working there
and [ __ ] yeah it is a hassle but with
like what cody's talking about you just
have multiple wallets in theory you
could just [ __ ] collude some prices
on nft no problem a friend of mine or
not a friend of mine he's not my friend
he used to he does stuff on ebay um i
won't say what but he used to bid on his
own [ __ ] with uh other accounts
like get the price that has to be
against the oh i'm sure that he can't do
it anymore because they probably you
know got his ip or whatever the hell
they do
ebay smart they got that
figured out yeah
but yeah there's uh people do it with
stocks too there's uh there have been
guys they get busted like there have
been
um
stories about just a couple of dudes who
have a million dollars between them and
they just keep buying and selling back
and forth to each other bidding the
price up ever higher and other people
catch on and then they just [ __ ] them
fine art is like a huge way to launder
your money because you can just roll up
a piece of art and you're just carrying
around well there's also this conspiracy
with artists too where
you know galleries will pick up art for
cheap and then like feed these artists
drugs and like take them to parties and
like try to increase their chances of
like [ __ ] overdosing what yeah that
is [ __ ] weird
conspiracy yeah yeah it's like yeah i
mean yeah
[Laughter]
look at the cup it says currently
caffeinated how cute is that you see
this yeah did you even know that it says
it's on these no you're currently
caffeinating caffeinating i can't even
read yeah hey ben can you
read the cup
sorry oh it's your caffeinated yeah but
who can eat more hot dogs uh i bet i
could eat more hot dogs
yeah but if veggie dogs were in the mix
do you guys think they'll let in the
july 4th coney island
competition they'll let veggie dogs you
mean next year next july yeah like 11
months away it's a lot of preparation
it's also the best event of the entire
year yeah what's the guy's name who won
johnny apple's seat isn't it no joey
joey chestnut tom brady
i saw a video of him chugging gatorade
yeah man he's branching out yeah trying
new things it was like a gallon of blue
gatorade didn't someone die choking to
death yeah one of them a couple of years
ago no no it was we for a wee it's that
famous story of this chick who like this
mom she downed like two gallons of water
to win a week a wii u and she died she
drowned yeah she's like god she drowned
she drowned dude what yeah yeah dark
[ __ ] man it was a radio contest yeah oh
damn that's a shitty way to go that is
all in an embarrassing reason yeah just
for a week
so you really have to pee right now
she's like something hurts
oh it's probably because of how bad you
have to pee the kids probably sued the
radio station oh i think they
i don't i kind of do they got them then
they got to go right back into still
whoa
we got more
i have a feeling that station got shut
down
they shouldn't get shut down the guys
probably got fired for sure so nfts man
were they all started by this guy no no
no no no faze banks did not invent nft
he's a gamer right
he's a gamer yeah he's a he's a phase
guy yeah
but no i mean did he start crypto punks
no no he didn't start it but he's he's a
big proponent he's a big proponent he's
like super into nfts and he's tweeting
all the time about like how much money
there is in nfts
made half a million dollar flip in in a
month i'm losing my [ __ ] mind right
now
but they're buying them for a ton of
money and then flipping them for even
more money yeah but it like it's really
hard to make this much if you don't have
it already right that's what's shitty is
like oh man there's so many people who
i'm sure would love to
participate in this but they can't
because the barrier to entry is so
damaging yeah but two years ago they
were all free they were free
people that minted them for free oh
my god
let's make it oh hey yeah relax what are
you doing
that's our child okay sorry
it's okay
do you want it yeah yeah
[Laughter]
there you go
it's fine
oh my god damn we had to get the baby
cleaned up yeah can we get the baby back
actually
thank you oh we didn't even talk about
the baby episode of love island oh yeah
you're right
oh that's like that's not right i feel
bad
what is so funny about a baby
a doll being tossed
that makes us laugh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]